voilà alexeï navalni sa détermination
son courage mais représente t'il
vraiment une menace pour vladimir
poutine qu'est-ce que son parcours nous
dit du système politique russe de ces
dérives de ses fragilités
navalni petit l'emporter d'autres
opposants prendront-ils la relève ce
sont quelques unes des questions que
nous allons nous poser après ce film
navalni l'homme qui défie le tsar
d'aurélie darblade et franck pennel et
pour approfondir à présent j'accueille
sur ce plateau gérard longuet bonjour
bonsoir est sénateur les républicains de
la meuse président du groupe
interparlementaire d'amitié france
russie à vos côtés clémentine fauconnier
bonjour vous êtes politologue maîtresse
de conférences à l'université de
haute-alsace spécialiste de la russie
nous sommes également en ligne avec
elena volochine bonjour vous êtes chef
du bureau de la chaîne france 24 à
moscou et avec bernard guetta bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen du
groupe
renew europe à l heure où m ancien
journaliste et vous avez été
correspondance est important de préciser
pour le quotidien le monde à moscou
alors d'abord une toute première
réaction à ce film que nous venons de
voir clémentine fauconnier est ce que
c'est un portrait fidèle de cet homme
qu'on présente je le disais comme un
temps quasiment l'ennemi personnel de
vladimir poutine
oui j'ai trouvé que documentaire était
très très bien fait parce qu'ils m'ont
très bien à la fois la trajectoire du
personnage dans tout ce qu'elle peut
avoir aussi de très cinégénique c'est à
dire que la grande force de la vanille
ça ça a été dit dans le documentaire
c'est que il a renouvelé complètement
les codes de l'opposition en russie
alors avec des succès dont il faudra
discuter ensuite parce que pour
l'instant il est en situation est très
difficile ainsi que tous ceux qui
l'entourent mais il a quand même
contribué à faire un tout petit peu
bouger le système poutine pas forcément
pour le meilleur pour l'instant le
système est plutôt en train de se durcir
mais de montrer finalement qu'il y avait
des ressources des possibilités pour
faire un tout petit peu pour ébranler un
tout petit peu ce système tellement bien
huilé elena volochine vous êtes d'accord
portrait fidèle de de cet homme
alexeï navalni moi je pense que ce qui
effectivement assez fidèle dans steam
c'est la notion de duel avec ses parties
d'échecs mise en scène sa direction de
duels vraiment un problème de machine
alexeï navalni ce moment le seul
véritable rival et munich adversaires ne
pas dire plus haut niveau politique en
russie maintenant sa série documentaire
n'a pas être robin accenture pitt ses
affaires judiciaires cette espèce de
diderot qui suit avec sa famille ses
proches sa famille depuis des années
maintenant il faut savoir que
l'excellent yamani si quelqu'un qui y
passait sa vie dans le tempo avant cette
condamnation à la prison ferme
son frère giovanni par exemple fait
quatre ans de prison
et c'est vraiment tout ce qui faisait
partie de son quotidien ses affaires
judiciaires sept français bernard guetta
on le fout ligne est un excellent
communicant alexeï navalni il a pris de
court le système poutine par ses
qualités de communicant chez la
rencontre d'un personnage et d'un moment
le personnage c'est une sorte de fanfan
la tulipe de domme extrêmement courageux
provocateur toujours le sourire l'éclat
de rire
et puis le moment le moment c'est une
période d'affaiblissement dans laquelle
est entrée le régime poutine
vous savez quand poutine arrive au
pouvoir il succède un homme déjà assez
âgées mal en point physiquement détruit
totalement détruit par un alcoolisme
chronique et poutine à ce moment là et
le jeune premier tout en muscles qui va
redonner une fierté à la russie une
estime d'elle-même
et puis ce qui se passe vingt ans après
et bien c'est finalement que navalni et
le nouveau jeune premier tout en muscles
qui redonne à la russie une estime
d'elle-même aussi par son courage et ses
provocations et ses révélations
naturellement qu'ils sont une chose très
très importante parce que les
révélations ben elle vise juste et
notamment sur la corruption
gérard longuet un mot quand même sur cet
homme alexeï navalni vous qui être qui
est président
de ce groupe interparlementaire d'amitié
france russie c'est quelqu'un quand on
est parlementaire français à la place
que vous occupez qu'on regarde avec
attention en se disant peut-être
sera-t-il un jour un interlocuteur pour
la france
en tous les cas comme un personnage je
le concède tout à fait exceptionnelle
sur le plan de la communication du
dynamisme de courage alors pour nous à
l'intérieur du groupe d'amitié
c'est en effet aussi une interrogation
sur le système politique en général
quand on adhère au groupe d'amitié
france russie c'est qu'on s'intéresse à
la russie qu'on a tendance à considérer
ce que je pense profondément que c'est
un pays non seulement important mais
décisif entre l'europe et l'asie et
l'asie chinoise en particulier que sa
direction politique est un sujet
d'étonnement permanent
navalni le regarder il a du poids
politique navalni alors c'est la vraie
question navale et à un poids médiatique
c'est incontestable un poids médiatique
en russie un poids mais est ce assez
mesuré d'ailleurs à travers les
manifestants qui l'ont suivi en au début
de l'année de 2 cette année même après
son incarcération en même temps on a du
mal à croire que ce soit un système
politique d'alternants alors c'est
intéressant parce que j'allais vous
posez la question tu es monté une
fauconnier le film parle beaucoup de son
aura médiatique qui vient d'être appelé
par gérard longuet mais on n'en sait pas
grand chose finalement en sortant de
tout ça sur ses idées
alexeï navalni alors s'il a l'occasion
de le préciser ça a été dit assez
rapidement dans le documentaire mais
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant de le
préciser il ya quelques quelques mois il
a donné une longue interview où il
explique quelles sont ses positions il
se positionne clairement au centre droit
c'est-à-dire défense de l'état de droit
défense de la liberté d'entreprendre
assez peu de questions sur la
distribution des ressources est
clairement pas il est clairement pas
du côté de la gauche voilà donc son
centre droit et ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est qu'il est l'occasion de
préciser un tout petit peu un épisode
particulier de son parcours quand il a
eu des positions assez nationalistes ont
évidemment et de la question est posée
pour le coup dans le fait de ses
affinités avec l'extrême droite voilà
donc là pour le coup il s'est
considérablement lissée
c'est à dire qu'il n'a plus du tout ce
type de discours quand il est interrogé
dessus à mon sens je trouve qu'il
continue à être un petit peu ambigu ce
qui est quand même très important dans
un état multinational comme la russie
qui n'est pas un état nation voilà donc
du coup la question de la pluralité
religieuse linguistique elle se pose
réellement il continue à être à mon sens
un tout petit peu flou sur ces questions
là qui sont pourtant très importante
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ce sont
ses idées aujourd'hui on a quand même
une idée assez assez claire de son
positionnement voilà assez pro
entreprise pro liberté et pour la
défense de l'état de droit ce qui est
une grave question en russie et sur la
question de la place de la russie dans
le monde de la nation elena volo ginès
qui se distingue d'une manière ou d'une
autre de vladimir poutine
la vanille c'est pas du tout quelqu'un
qui a un programme de politique
étrangère à une mission pour la russie
dans le monde qu'on peut la voir les
admire comptines la manif c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui est axé sur son credo à
savoir la lutte anticorruption et a
fortiori pas puisqu'il a été poursuivi
pendant toutes ces années sur la
question des prisonniers politiques et
l'état de droit
et effectivement ils n'aiment pas
s'exprimer cette étrangère donc je ne
dirais pas que c'est quelqu'un qui a
vraiment des visées politiques de la
cour si bernard guetta il
il est régulièrement accusé navalni
d'être un agent de l'étranger pour
travailler pour le compte d d d d
américains des européens
l'irt un classique
en russie mais ça repose sur quelque
chose non tout opposant tout opposant à
vladimir poutine est immédiatement
accusée par le régime d'être un agent de
l'étranger et entre les lignes d'être un
agent des états unis donc rien là de 9
ce nom est lui-même n'est absolument pas
un homme de l'étranger au contraire il a
commencé on vient de le dire et à juste
titre il a commencé comme non content de
tendance très très nationaliste est
assez à droite extrême droite je ne
dirais pas ça mais très très à droite
oui très à droite une droite
nationaliste et dur et aujourd'hui c'est
un libéral ou deux sens du thème c'est à
dire un libéral en économie est un
libéral dans le domaine des libertés
publiques
il s'est considérablement rapproché des
valeurs défendues dans les traités
constitutifs de l'union européenne et il
s'est considérablement rapprochée
j'entends politiquement parlant
intellectuellement parlant de l'union
européenne qu'il qui constitue
aujourd'hui à ses yeux un modèle gérard
longuet sur cette question voilà d'un
opposant qui est régulièrement taxé par
par vladimir poutine d'être un agent ou
le régime poutine d'être un agent de
l'étranger
est-ce qu'il est est ce qu'on peut
considérer que parfois l'europe les
etats-unis ont pu chercher aussi
instrumentalisée navalni contre pour
affaiblir poutine et inversement
je dirais inversement parce que navel me
pose un problème aux européens il pose
un problème aux américains les allemands
par exemple sont très gênés dans cette
affaire ils ont accueilli
navalni ils l'ont soigné madame merkel
lui a rendu visite ce qui était une
forme d'hommage et de reconnaissance
simultanément les allemands souhaitent
aboutir avec norkring 2 et
les gazoducs c'est le projet de gazoduc
n'est sisyphe pour l'allemagne nouvelle
nice et ça complique un peu le relais
c'est un caillou dans la chaussure des
relations russo allemandes mais on en
france aussi d'ailleurs vizier dans les
deux sens de fait il peut aussi être
utilisé par les européens contre directs
vers les amena dire qu'un américain plus
par les américains au fond ce qu'on voit
c'est que joe biden a décidé de
reprendre contact avec les russes il ya
eu cette rencontre de genève
les européens ne l'ont pas été associé à
main à mon à ma connaissance pas été
prévenus ni de l'ordre du jour ni des
conclusions possibles et navel n'y joue
un rôle bien involontairement c'est pas
sa démarche personnelle mais ça permet
aux états unis de dire à ceux des
européens qui veulent la rupture avec la
russie je consomme ni baltes la pologne
la roumanie le 10 rebonds voyez avec
l'exemple de navalni ans on peut rien
faire avec ces gens là
et de l'autre côté un pays comme la
france celle de emmanuel macron le
président macron souhaitait trouver des
relations plus apaisées avec la russie
très honnêtement ça lui compliquer la
vie et on l'a sentiment qu'il a
c'est une poule avec un couteau ils
n'ont pas très bien comment ça commence
ici je vais vous poser la question avec
l'anah volochine vous qui suivez
voila voila l'actualité pour france 24 à
moscou du poids politique réel
aujourd'hui de deux navalni parce qu'on
l'a bien on l'a dit il a une surface
médiatique c'est indéniable mais
politiquement
voilà est-ce qu'il pèse aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il a les moyens de peser dans
dans la vie politique russe
distingué d'abord c'est la popularité la
visibilité avec senna va mixer ensuite
ce sont ses chances réelles de percer
dans un système politique est totalement
parle de sa popularité
indéniablement au vu des derniers
épisodes de cet épisode d'empoisonnement
et d'entraînement elle a bondi en flèche
lui qui était soit vous disais d'enfield
une opacité du par les médias d'état
alors complètement adhéré vilipendé
au final tout le monde a entendu parler
de plus en russie et de ce qui lui est
arrivé on l'a vu lors des dernières
manifestations les gens qui sont sortis
manifester ce n'est pas le noyau
manifester avant ce sont des gens plutôt
apolitiques qui ne soutenaient pas
forcément la vanille mais qui dit non
c'est un justice pour non donc
finalement faire de lui un martyr
ça c'est quelque chose qui a plutôt
réussi et a fait exploser sa popularité
maintenant pour ce qui est de la menace
il faut voir les chances d'alexei la
vanille d'aboutir à devenir
véritablement à l'adversaire dans
l'arène politique et ça ça parait que
c'est compliqué parce que le système il
a été de plus en plus forte ces
dernières années aujourd'hui il est
complètement complètement amorphe ce
système mais cette fois on y voit pour
les élections législatives à venir la
prochaine élection présidentielle
simplement fait changer la constitution
pour dire je n'ai jamais des présidents
on recommence c'est comme si je n'y
avais jamais pas se représenter
dans ce système et en plus dirigé par
les services secrets
ça paraît très compliqué pour un
opposant sa place il ya quelque chose de
très intéressant dans ce dans ce
documentaire c'est cette bataille des
récits sur l'empoisonnement d'alexei
notamment ce que navalni présente comme
un échange téléphonique avec l'un des
agents qui auraient participé à cet
empoisonnement je vous propose qu'on
regarde à nouveau cet extrait pions en
parler après cette enquête est le fruit
d'une collaboration avec belinga
d'insiders cnn el país ou der spiegel
belinga tu avais une liste de numéros de
téléphone qu'ils ont appelé eux mêmes le
plan est simple vous recevez un appel à
7 heures du matin vous voyez un numéro
familier vous décrocher le téléphone et
commençait à parler
presque tous ceux que j'ai appelés ont
répondu et presque tous ont raccroché
rapidement et puis la chance allait nous
sourit avec we are thème bonjour comme
stan constantine
bonjour à constantine morisod beach je
dois juste écrire un rapport rassemblant
les témoignages des membres de ton
équipe
que s'est il passé pourquoi l'opération
à tomsk a échoué le voyage a été
raccourci si l'avion avait atterri à
l'heure prévue tout temps été différent
quelle était la procédure que deviez
vous faire je dois faire un rapport
nous lui avons appliqué le produit
allant le voir c'est absolument
rocambolesque
la russie elle parle de falsification à
ce sujet bernard guetta sur ce point
voilà y'a aucun doute aujourd'hui sur le
fait que le régime est impliqué d'une
manière ou d'une autre dans dans cet
empoisonnement mais comment ça il n'est
pas un clic et d'une manière ou d'une
autre il est totalement d'impliquer le
président poutine est évidemment donné
l'ordre
ça ne se passe pas aussi directement que
ça on sous-entend a évidemment donné
l'ordre d'empoisonner d'empoisonner
alexeï navalni comme il avait donné
l'ordre d'empoisonner d'autres gêneurs
en grande bretagne
précédemment le poison qui a été
empoisonnée n'est pas en vente libre ce
n'est pas de la mort aux rats
c'est un produit extraordinairement
sophistiqué qui sort des laboratoires
militaires et qui avait été inventée
d'ailleurs du temps de l'union
soviétique qui sortent des laboratoires
ministère évidemment que alexeï navalni
a été l'objet d'une tentative
d'assassinât
alors pourquoi at il été l'objet d'une
tentative d'assassinât
tout simplement parce que ce régime
s'est affaibli considérablement ce
régime est dans une situation d'impasse
en syrie parce que il a gagné la guerre
mais il est incapable de gagner la paix
ce régime est dans une impasse dans ce
qui constitué hier les anciennes les
républiques soviétiques y sont
aujourd'hui des états indépendants
monsieur poutine de contrôle plus
totalement ce qui se passe dans ces
républiques regarder ce qui se passe en
arménie en ukraine évidemment
biélorussie évidemment mais aussi en
kirghizie en moldavie etc etc
et puis le niveau de vie baisse parce
que la situation économique est mauvaise
puis monsieur poutine est au pouvoir
depuis 20 ans et n'incarne plus la
revanche historique à laquelle
aspiraient les russes il ya vingt ans la
période politique a totalement changé et
monsieur poutine a aujourd'hui peur et
c'est pour ça qu'il fait modifier la
constitution c'est pour ça qu'il élimine
toutes les formes
d'opposition possible et en ce sens
monsieur navalni est un révélateur est
un accélérateur en même temps et surtout
un révélateur de l'affaiblissement de ce
régime est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça clémentine fauconnier cet
empoisonnement ce basculement finalement
dans dans dans l'histoire récente de la
russie c'est un signe de
l'affaiblissement de la fragilité de
lanières poutine oui tout à fait parce
que jusque là la stratégie vladimir
poutine et son entourage c'était plutôt
de traiter navalni et les opposants
générale par le mépris c'est à dire de
changer les lois pour écarter les
opposants qui dérangeait navale dit
comme ça a été rappelé plus tôt de faire
en sorte de sous traiter je dirais le
travail de répression plus tôt en lui en
lui collant des procès et c est là il a
fallu finalement ce qui a été inévitable
pour l'admirer poutine c'est de se
retrouver au moins symboliquement dans
une situation de duel avec un homme plus
jeune
désormais plus musclé plus vigoureux qui
n'a pas peur et donc du coup de se
retrouver face à quelqu'un qui chasse
sur cette terre sur ce qui a fait le
pilier de sa légitimité et vous avez
bien fait de montrer l'extrait que vous
venez de diffuser à l'instant je pense
qu'en fait c'est fondamental c'est
peut-être le moment le plus important
finalement de tout cet tout cet arc
narratif pour reprendre une métaphore
cinématographique mais c'était pas gagné
depuis son empoisonnement le l'autre
maman c'est quand il a décidé de rentrer
qu'il a fait montre d'un courage
extraordinaire parce qu'ils savaient
bien qu'ils allaient jeter dans la
gueule du loup
mais l'autre maman c'est quand il a
réussi à piéger et on voit l'émotion de
son équipe autour de lui parce que le
fsb donc les services secrets russes
c'est la colonne vertébrale du système
poutine poutine en est l ancien chef
c'est une institution qui à la fois
crainte est très respecté par la russie
la navale y est arrivé à montrer qu'ils
n'avaient pas peur et qui pouvaient la
ridiculiser et la mettre finalement en
défaut donc il s'est attaqué je dirai au
pilier le plus fondamental du système
poutine
gérard longuet on peut discuter avec un
homme qui commanditent l'assassinât
l'élimination de ses opposants mais dans
les deux cas qu'ils les commandités ou
qui ne l'est pas commandité c'est une
affaire perdante pour lui qu'il ait
commandité pour la raison que vous me
dire les les et or le sens de leurs
intérêts parfois un peu de cynisme on le
leur reproche
mais c'est quand même un obstacle majeur
pour pouvoir discuter en confiance et
signe de la part demandé formellement
ça veut dire qu'il est il ne contrôle
pas ses services le fsb en particulier
et une fraction
de ses services c'est donc une sorte de
faiblesse public donc le l'attentât est
une faiblesse public
le retour en russie est également un
acte de courage mais aussi un formidable
acte de communication vis-à-vis de
l'intérieur et de l'extérieur
je crois que le ressort de navalni
puisque vous posez la question c'est
celle eu le courage l'audace pour
dénoncer ce que les russes dans leur
ensemble et dire comment ne le feraient
ils pas dénoncent la corruption de
certains tous non de certains et veulent
t'ils pour autant de navalni ça c'est
beaucoup moins probable
elena volochine c'est intéressant parce
qu'on parle de courage physique depuis
tout à l'heure de 2,2 navalni et
finalement il en fait une sorte de
preuve de l'authenticité de ce qu'il dit
puisque il est comme ça vient d'être dit
par clémentine le fauconnier il est prêt
à se jeter dans la gueule du loup pour
apporter la preuve de sa sincérité et de
la vérité de ce qu'il avance oui mais
c'est à dire que la valise qu'il sait
c'est que ce régime il est tellement
fort il est tellement humble
la seule chose finalement qui pourra à
l'ébranler un tant soit peu c'est un
sacrifice
c'est une mort un martyr encore une fois
ces décès de se porter comme ça de se
sacrifier finalement pour montrer
regarder ce régime il est cannibale il
ya eu l'assassinât de boris nemtsov
il ya quelques années d'autres besoins
bands of autant il était difficile de
relier directement pas tenir poutine à
cet assassinat il était en situation
d'une application potentielle du
détecteur prochaines 24 heures mais
autant c'était difficile et c'est
toujours aujourd'hui difficile de parler
de voir clairement ce qu'il s'est passé
c'est pourtant avec alexeï navalni c'est
absolument évident on ne peux pas
supposer que vladimir poutine ne
contrôle pas ses services secrets
vladimir poutine c'est un ancien chef de
service secret est aujourd'hui les
services secrets mettent en place
exactement tout ce désordre reproduit
exactement le même système qui existait
à l'époque solitude
évidemment comme vladimir poutine
commandité cet assassinat
vous n'avez pas huit agents secrets du
baiser qui suivent un opposant dans tous
ses déplacements pendant trois ans sans
le chef du kremlin
on ne l'est pas ordonner ça c'est
absolument clair et beau aujourd'hui la
famille en trois ans rossi en sachant
pertinemment qu'il va aller dans un
système de mon droit total nous
valorisons fiction à la merci de cette
fois tenté de l'assassiner
il sait parfaitement ce coupé et il sait
qu on sait que la seule chose de seul
moyen plus courir tout être ébranlé cela
jean et qu'est ce qui pourrait ébranler
ce régime c'est le fait que les gens
lewus finalement 10
on ne veut plus de ce régime et qu'ils
cessent d'avoir peur oui et c'est pour
ça que la vanille leur dis n'ayez pas
peur
sortez dans les rues et c'est pour ça
qu'il va this pour vous y compris à ce
jour une petite parenthèse sur sur
l'homme et sur sur ses ressorts
intérieurs parce que quand on est prêt
comme ça risquait sa vie
clémentine fauconnier pour une cause
politique
il est il est at t on qu'il a assez peu
abordés dans le film et que c'est un
homme de foi par ailleurs oui oui au
pied un peu super c'est une vocation
ancien il fait de la politique depuis
très longtemps alors saisi de façon il
ya eu plusieurs moments où vous le dites
dans le documentaire avant d'être un
blogueur il a toujours fait de la
politique il a toujours milité au parti
iabloko d'abord et puis ensuite il a été
bloqué avocats etc
mais quand même son voile à la colonne
vertébrale je dirais de sa vie c'est
quand même là la politique au départ et
puis je pense qu'il a il a vu aussi que
ce qu'il proposait ça pouvait
fonctionner leur fonctionner en partie
mais en tout cas révélé comme c'était
très bien dit à plusieurs reprises à la
fois il brûlait un tout petit peu le
régime poutine et puis révéler tout ce
qu'il avait de violents tout ce qu'ils
avaient aussi je dirais d'user
aujourd'hui puisque finalement la seule
solution de poutine finalement
aujourd'hui c'est la coercition c'est la
répression ce qui était un petit peu
moins le cas au tout début de son
arrivée si on parle de l'homme toujours
aussi parlé de son de son épouse conquis
et qui est très présent dans le film et
qui tient un rôle là aussi très
important dans son engagement dans son
itinéraire
oui oui et c'est d'ailleurs sa famille
est très mise en avant de façon générale
ça c'est intéressant c'est que c'est
aussi un contraste supplémentaires
gradimir poutine qui reste très secret
sur sa vie familiale qui est divorcé
depuis longtemps mais qui se met
toujours en scène un homme seul sans
famille sans vie personnelle et c'est là
où la vanille alors on pourrait aussi y
voir une référence aux modes de
communication américain il ya quelque
chose d'un petit peu kennedy obama dans
cette tradition là de mettre en avant sa
famille sur instagram s'était dit aussi
dans le documentaire on le voit avec ses
enfants avec sa femme
ce qui est intéressant aussi celle
ioulia d'havana ya à mon sens c'est que
ça permet de faire des parallèles avec
ce qui s'est passé au bélarus
cet été où finalement ce sont les
épouses d'une certaine façon qui
prennent parfois le relais des maris qui
se sont en partie sacrifier finalement
alors il faut composer la question de
tout de ce vers quoi cela mène nous mène
enfin mène la russie quel est l'avenir
des oppositions en russie je vous pose
la question avoue bernard guetta parce
qu'on a un peu l'impression vous parlez
de fanfan la tulipe tout à l'heure à
propos de nouvelles ni voilà ça me tout
cela ne manque pas de panache évidemment
mais à ce jour politiquement en tout cas
c'est un échec
non non non non pas du tout pas du tout
parce que j'avale dit navalni a inventé
une chose qu'il a appelé le vote utile
c'est à dire de voter pour n'importe
quel candidat quel qu'il soit quel que
soit sa couleur politique
voter pour n'importe quel candidat
pourvu qu'il ne soit pas le candidat 2
poutine du parti de poutine
et bien cette tactique tant que toute
forme d'opposition n'a pas été interdit
a rencontré un très grand succès dans
des élections locales
non seulement elle a rencontré un très
grand succès mais elle a été exportée
elle s'est exportée en hongrie où toutes
les oppositions se sont coalisés contre
viktor orban et ont peut-être une
possibilité assez grande possibilité de
remporter les élections législatives de
l'année prochaine d'aval ni avec le vote
utile à inventer une forme de combat et
d'opposition
qui non seulement a rencontré un grand
succès en russie mais a rencontré un
grand succès international man parlant
puisqu'elle s'est exportée non on
regarde la belle ou parce qu'il nous
reste quelques minutes je vous propose
qu'on regarde un très court extrait de
notre de notre documentaire ce sont ces
images voilà que nous avons tous vu mais
qu'il est bon de bonbons de revoir cet
appel à manifester lancé par navalni et
ses images de rassemblement on va
reparler après
il
je suis allé à cette manifestation
non pas parce que je supporte un côté ou
l'autre
en vérité la raison principale est mon
ras-le-bol du modèle politique actuelle
et du fonctionnement de ce gouvernement
la chose qui m'a étonné le plus pendant
ces manifestations c'est qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde
contrairement à d'habitude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pièce pour être honnête avant ça je ne
pensais pas qu'on pouvait arriver à une
telle situation qu'un gouvernement je
s'essayer de tuer un des citoyens de son
pays avec une arme interdite sur nos
marges
aujourd'hui c'est lui demain ça peut
être toi elena volochine ces images de
rassemblements de manifestations est ce
qu'elles ont la moindre chance de
déboucher à un moment ou à un autre sur
un réseau résultat électoral défavorable
à vladimir poutine ou bien enfin le
système comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure et complètement bloquée moi je
suis assez pessimiste par rapport à ça
d'abord on voit ce qui s'est passé en
2010 avec ses énormes prestations
suite à la réélection de blaise et
marketing ou moins poussés à rien
puisqu'il y avait eu un début de
répression qui ont appris que sa propre
dupuis convoi avec les élections
législatives de septembre thx et que le
système a été encore plus et rien pas
plus qu'il ne l'était avant tout les
candidats indépendants qui sont écartés
alors oui évidemment il peut être utile
non par les anciens collègues tout à
l'heure mais mais mais les problèmes dus
soit utile c'est aussi que les
technologies mises en place par le
kremlin pour assurer une victoire à son
parti un groupe chimique et aujourd'hui
est extrêmement impopulaire
cette technologie réduit me pète que
l'on met en place un certain nombre un
nombre très important d'ailleurs de faux
entre guillemets candidats d'opposition
donc on est tendu de technologique
explique contexte où tout est mia
compulsion la coupe à bandes
les avocats pour faire aimer des
candidats qui sont finalement soit dans
une émission c'était midi soit ceux de
rossini et on voit aussi que platine et
qu'il modifie en permanence les lois ou
dérouillée de plus en plus au système
par exemple le dernier en date
tous ceux qui ont été une passion d'une
autre la marlin passé à qu'il ya une
organisation d'extrémistes ne peuvent
plus participer à la vie politique et
services directement tout ce réseau de
milliers de partisans de l'allier
comment pessimiste par rapport aux
chances de l'opposition en politique par
rapport au système
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu d'ailleurs
lors des précédentes élections locales
il y avait des candidats de l'édition
qui ont emporté des postes au niveau
local cette fois je pense que le système
est par ce dernier
clémentine fauconnier ce système est
est-il verrouiller les manifestants
qu'on venait de voir qu'on vient de voir
sur ces images
ont-ils la moindre chance de constituer
un moment ou à un autre notamment pour
les législatives de cet automne une
force qui met ces petites d'inquiéter
vladimir poutine je suis malheureusement
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit je suis aussi assez
pessimiste c'est à dire que le système a
été ébranlée clairement mais pour
l'instant la réponse c'est la répression
et avec des instruments qui sont encore
solides
voilà et qui font que même s'il ya on
voit ce qui s'est passé au bélarus aussi
qui est beaucoup moins gros morceau pour
le dire rapidement qu'à russie c'est à
dire que on peut avoir un mouvement de
mobilisation assez fort en partie
soutenue par la population mais qui peut
être réprimé des candidats qui sont
réprimées aussi et je pense que le
système poutine a des fondements encore
suffisamment solides pour pouvoir tenir
longtemps tenir sous un format beaucoup
plus usé que ce qu'il était mais ton il
ya dix ans
mais tenir encore et avec donc une
opposition et une population qui vont
être soumis à des à des contraintes de
plus en plus importante c'est ce qu'on
voit depuis dix ans et avec une
accélération depuis l'année dernière
gérard longuet que peu feu que peuvent
faire les européens dans une situation
comme celle-ci ont-ils les moyens des
motifs des leviers pour favoriser
l'avènement de la démocratie en russie
à ta question à savoir que veulent les
européens vis-à-vis de la russie et
s'agit-il d'influer sur l'évolution de
la russie
ou s'agit-il d'obtenir d'elle une
attitude de coopération sur des objets
de tensions internationales le proche
orient la relation avec la chine
relations que les états unis la
situation dans l'arctique par exemple
est très clairement les européens n'ont
pas encore aujourd'hui fixer leurs
priorités nous avons un lot de pays qui
sont profondément anti russe est
parfaitement méfiants les français les
allemands étant beaucoup plus
pragmatique vis-à-vis de l'ag comtesse
en rien l'esprit démocratique allemand
et nous revendiquons toujours d'être la
patrie des droits de l'homme
enfin vis-à-vis de la russie on a des
objectifs beaucoup plus terre à terre
beaucoup plus concret et qui peut
d'ailleurs se comprendre je n'en fais
pas le procès parce que la russie c'est
d'abord et avant tout 17 me donne
kilomètres carrés et ça c'est
incontestable et incontournable et c'est
pas nous qui allons les gérer donc là on
est obligé de faire avec
en revanche il se sort ma conclusion
interrogé poutine sur navalni n'est pas
un élément de faiblesse bien au
contraire dans la convergence dans les
échanges que nous avons avec le pouvoir
de moscou
je vous pose la même question voilà que
que peut faire surtout que veut l'europe
face à vladimir poutine
ce sera évidemment assez rapide merci
elle souhaite que la russie évoluent
vers la démocratie mais ça c'est un
souhait elle veut à tout prix éviter la
formation d'un bloc sino russe qui
serait une fatalité 1 suscite tout
simplement pour la russie parce que une
alliance entre le lièvre est le tigre on
sait généralement comment ça se termine
alors évidemment qu'il ya aujourd'hui
les choses bougent dans tous les sens
les choses bougent dans tous les sens et
on voit que monsieur poutine cherche
désespérément aujourd'hui à trouver un
modus vivendi avec les états unis est à
mes yeux à mon avis de bain il cherchera
aussi un modus vivendi avec l'union
européenne parce que il en a besoin tout
simplement il en a besoin parce que la
chine est parce que son régime ça fait
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
de nous avoir éclairé
je renvoie votre livre clémentine
fauconnier entre le marteau et l'enclume
la fabrication d'une hégémonie partisane
dans la russie de poutine c'est au
septentrion paru en 2010 neuf autres
conseils de lecture poutine la stratégie
du désordre dit isabelle mandraud
journaliste au monde correspondante en
russie de 2014 à 2010
fait de julien theron par uc taillandier
et puis la russie de poutine en 100
questions de tatiana castillet valjean
aux éditions tallandier merci à chacun
et à chacune de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]